thank you and thank you for inviting me
to be on this panel which caused me to
stop and reflect and to really come to
appreciate in a way I hadn't before how
much I owe the Yale graduate school I
want to dedicate my remarks to two
people kingman brewster for whom I
served as chief of staff and my
dissertation advisor John Morton Blum
who died a couple weeks ago and we had
his service here in battelle just just a
week ago tomorrow what I'm about to say
reflects what I learned from them both
in and beyond the classroom I majored in
history here as an undergraduate so I
was doubly blessed studied twice with
the likes of ed Morgan Howard Lamar then
Woodward gatos meath John Blum and what
was I think still the Golden Age of
American history at Yale and since I've
been privileged to lead the new school
as it reconnected to its European roots
by helping dissident scholars and East
and Central Europe in the 1980s Linda
chair Human Rights Watch as it expanded
to Africa and Asia to be president of
the MacArthur Foundation which works on
community development and education in
the US and globally on conservation
population Human Rights peace and
security in 60 countries and happy to
say with an office in Mexico and I have
no doubt that my apprenticeship with
Kingman and my historical training at
the Graduate School were key ingredients
to whatever good I've been able to do in
any of those leadership opportunities so
let me cite seven lessons and learnings
the first is that leadership can be
dominated by problems and can be
reactive but history tells me and
example reaffirms that moments of crisis
can be turned to good purpose and so
I've always looked for the opportunity
in a problem not been put on the
defensive and consumed by the negative
and put my energy in to as the song says
accentuating the positive number two
John Blum used to say and I can hear it
now nothing is inevitable people can
make or shape the course and turn the
tide of history and that advice was
never more useful than in Prague 1989
when I just by accident happened to be
sitting at the key moment with the
leaders of the Velvet Revolution when
they were trying to decide whether this
was the moment whether to press ahead
and pursue this revolution if they had
it wrong they'd be in jail and if they
didn't press ahead and it was the moment
they would forever be regretful third my
approach to any situation whether unrest
on campus and I had lots of that to deal
with here Yale ethnic strife in Africa
or struggles to conserve land rich in
biodiversity my approach is to
understand the historical context and
how different issues intersect and as
gana Smith taught me try to appreciate
the life experience of the people in
conflict or who must make common cause
to achieve a desired outcome so my first
step in any situation is an historical
analysis trying to understand who's
there what their history is how they see
the what lens they see the problem
through number four is timing matters
and I'll never forget stopping a walk
with King went across the quadrant angle
there by the fly
and had a really tough time during May
Day and he said you know when you run an
institution you have to know when to be
decisive or peer decisive on occasion to
be indecisive or appear indecisive and
so we all know there are opportunities
missed because the moment passed didn't
act when we should have wore failure was
suffered because the moment for action
wasn't right so knowing where you are in
the arc of history has been important to
me in deciding where to invest time and
effort and that's never been more
critical than my human rights work where
are the problems around the world are so
vast the resources to confront those
problems so inadequate and so you have
to pick your moments you have to know
get the timing right number five and
here I think of Howard llamar history
helps us understand the problems are not
solved or opportunity seized in the
short run patience is important as is
the capacity to peer over the horizon
and project forward from historical
trends and progress is ordinarily made
in increments provided there are there
are purposeful steps that are understood
and placed in a context in historical
context so progress is really a nut
proposition rarely a study linear march
but hope determination and motivation to
sacrifice and risk depend on some
visible reinforcements and so when I was
at MacArthur I understood if you wanted
to advance human rights in Russia
probably not going to confront the
Kremlin have on but you could take on an
issue like police reform the aspect of
government ordinary people see every day
the
lease and try to get that right or in
China very hard to work but we were able
to start a system of public defenders
working in the rural countryside or in
Cuba not an easy place to work but there
an authoritarian government persuaded
that conservation was it's an best
interest moved ahead in a very good way
number six getting close to the end I
think it was Vann Woodward who helped me
understand how to seek common ground how
to search for compromise without
sacrificing core principles and also to
be careful about strident ideology
invoked with too much passion that
narrows a space for reasonable people to
differ but to go on persevere and search
and finally from ed Morgan I've always
believed that ideas matter you can be
cynical but I'm not I do believe that
ideas influence policy values and
principles grounded in rigorous thinking
and expressed in charter documents can
make a difference over time and the
international human rights movement
fortified by treaties and covenants most
noticeably the universal declaration is
a good example of how ideas can
gradually change behavior and that's
happened really since 78 most
dramatically so in conclusion I never
had a second thought about pursuing
history rather than law which had been
my alternative but when I came to the
graduate school in my knight and my 30s
I understood I was never going to be a
great scholar even though I love
teaching but I believe that a deep
immersion in history was the best
preparation I could have for a life of
public service and so i'm grateful that
i did my study here at a university and
a graduate school which honors and
encourages giving back to society
thank you